this is furniture and meet another in
the series of episodes a he has not seen
and by the way we do have a Rainicorn
here as well she's good - MJ - she's
gonna say hello right now say hello
Rainicorn wow it's like she has two
voices it's those double vocal cords
they're androids have yeah so yeah so
this is a furniture indeed I love the
title yeah I don't know where it was
going yeah so it starts off Finn and
Jake are like we have all this money
what should we do with it they never
really thought about they just like
collecting it because they liked going
out of bed juries and they get rewards
and loot and stuff so finally they
decide to apparently put it to good use
so they go to the wild berry Kingdom and
they just put a bunch of money in the
fountain not really knowing what to do
with it and they find they buy the guard
off who's gonna arrest them but they
just like oh yeah it walks off and then
they get too greedy because they figure
out how to spend money again this sword
kind of apparently and they just sort of
pay people to do silly things
particularly Jake and eventually they go
too far and they're they're gonna you
know they they get too cocky and then
too powerful they're like okay we gotta
get rid of this oh they're gonna give it
to wildberry princess except that Jake
wants to sit on her which so he does
that in a way you wouldn't they not the
way you're thinking necessarily um
necessarily ending and maybe that's the
way they're thinking yeah it could be
Friday yeah maybe you're five watching
this and you're just like I eat Transpo
it's either yes yes that's what you're
all thinking and he goes and gets her
really angry and so she tries to have
them boiled in liquid gold but then BMO
comes to save the day as Robin Hood
because that's her thing now and they
they they take you know she gets them
out and they go home they just have one
coin left and they now put it in their
big treasure room because that was going
to be starting the beginning of more
getting a booty um yeah
so it's it's kind of straightforward is
what you think it's gonna be but I think
there's something funny about the idea I
like that because people always say you
know money is the root of all evil on
stuff I serve like it's the spending of
the money is what you do with the money
and in turn what that kind of does to
you because it's like they've had the
money for a long time and mints this is
just a world where at least for them I
mean they don't have to pay any rent
they just sort of got stuff made their
tree and they're able to find food on
their own and then that's how crazy
kitty um and yeah they seem to find so
then I like the any of them learning how
to spend yeah learning how to be greedy
essentially I like to just don't get the
whole spending I mean cuz yeah like even
stuff they get from my choose goose and
whatnot it's like they never have to pay
for anything it's just like they're
always given it because they're always
doing good things for everyone else yeah
until I go spend spend yeah it's sort of
like if anyone was learning this this is
kind of how it would go I think it's
like wow we can't make people do stupid
things that's kind of fine let's do it
again let's do it again then they don't
realize how like really power-hungry and
terrible they're becoming oh but that'd
be so much fun though well when we kind
of saw that I mean it's like when Finn
comes out covered in that purple yeah he
wishes I mean he's probably just killed
one of those Barry guy he sings like
covered with it um you know good a few
good laughs it um you know it's not like
one of my big favorites or anything but
you know it totally served as a bowling
fine and young God teaches like I said
kind of an obvious lesson but at the
same time it's very it's not just them
getting money it's they've always had
the money mm-hmm you know which i think
is good kind of for kids it's not
getting the money or having a lot money
it's sort of what you do with it and and
how you spend it so uh I want to do that
I wish I had that much money to just
kind of run around and cuz that's fine
I've done a lot it's great fun I mean
the best part is is that yeah it's not
like this money really means anything to
them and then like they find out oh
people are willing to do Stu
good crap just for this I I'm sorry I
like what Jake said they're doing it
because they want to they can say no and
I mean I kind of have to agree with that
if people are dumb enough to do stupid
if they're dumb enough to eat the money
to get some money they're being stupid
and they kind of get what they deserve I
mean if you're that dumb I mean I did
like the guy who is the dancer and he's
like he's dead like boring I'm bored now
do it more I'm just throwing all the the
coins item and it makes me think of
Mystery Science Theater she's an artist
do not throw pennies at her and it's
like a dig I turn into a hooker or a
stripper I am or just throwing coins at
boy I miss that one in this Oh Oh in
misty no they say you know she's an
artist don't throw pennies at her oh and
like that's what Jake turned in started
doing you started just throwing random
coins at the guy who was dancing and I'm
like oh my god it's like he's a stripper
all of a sudden it's this cessation
nothing he's a good dancer and I'm sorry
if you won to dance I mean there you go
the guard had the best idea though don't
do that don't do that I did like the
song that little son did you do my money
yeah I want that like on I want a
recording and bad or something cuz I
thought that was cuz I was thinking too
like I can't do the money what I like to
see you entry dirty messy and I'd love
to see someone like make a video game
like if not of this scenario just
someone else like just a rich guy going
off and it's how much he can pay off all
these people to do terrible things you
know just like you know need ten
thousand or three thousand but okay cop
goes away just keeps going you know so
how quickly can you get the money bags
to people before they arrest you I play
that yeah like there's a clever
commentary game in there somewhere but
we're also missing a few points here
well
one we saw nectar it also saw the tandem
elephant he returned finally after all
these episodes and it was night Swansea
is my punishment
I loved I'm glad to see what happened to
him I love that Bhima fires the elephant
which knocks the molten lava or melted
gold on to the guard
yeah that's pretty nice like that's
pretty rough and brutal and lastly once
again I mean the displace into the
flexible reality I mean how why the hell
couldn't Jake get out of those rogues
that makes no sense
that's just part of the you know
whatever I just look people being like I
was aiming for the rope oh that I got it
right in Jake's armpit yeah man I just
took it off I don't know I find it funny
and bizarre and strange and for some
reason like hey everyone always says
money is the root of all evil
not really and I think you're right it's
what you do with it yeah you know I mean
anything can be the root of all evil if
you let it consume you exactly you know
the only thing was not consumed by it
you saw the two personalities were
funerals kind of like yeah go do some
cool stuff we'll get some furniture and
whatnot but then when Jake started to
get kind of like a little bit bonkers
Finn's like no no no no no this is not
really that cool hmm and you know so it
shows that not everyone can get
corrupted by it well you know we went to
UM we went to the one step campaign they
invited us up on the clay that that's a
camp for children they have cancer oh
wait we did the charity drive for them
last year and they invited us up and
it's really what if I could do a whole
video on that but it's just funny that
when people say you know money is the
root of all evil it's just that black
and white I mean I just want to see like
whenever you know they're using that
donation some good use just like thank
you remember money is the root of all
evil you know it's just like there's
some things or it's like no money if
used right like anything like any tool
you know it can be good oh yeah you just
have to know how to use and not let it
consume you and that would be you know
the one thing in life yeah I think that
black and whites our way of looking at
things is what is what gets people in
those states to begin
you know money you know money is going
money is bad it's like anything oh yeah
it can be whatever you make of it I mean
it did and a lot of people will bring up
whole apparently you've never been poor
or you know something along those lines
it's like being down numerous roads and
whatnot
it doesn't matter if you come from a
poor family a rich family or whatever
you know it's again what you do with it
how you deal with it and all that stuff
and I think a lot of people use their
past experiences as a crutch instead of
saying oh you know what not everyone
that is rich is an ass not everyone that
makes a ton of money is a total jerk-off
and they're just evil people you know I
think everyone should take a look at
each person for who they are not for
what they have or don't have yeah and
there's certainly I've known actually
know a couple people that uh well we
thought that I think everybody has it
you know has known a lot of people of
different you know income some various
and their poorest on our middle class
upper middle class or lower middle class
or whatever and every single one of them
you know uses their status in a
different way or you know some are
totally happy where they are whether it
be dirt poor or sting of rich and some
are miserable with a bitter poor
stinking rich yeah I mean there are some
people I just look at you it you know
look at the person I just saying how can
you be miserable you have all this stuff
you know it's a lot of people that do
the lottery I mean if you're doing the
lottery to think this is gonna make me
happy it's it's not just gonna magnify
whenever you're feeling at the moment
yeah you know and but then I see people
with like not a cent I mean just like
nothing to their name and just happiest
people in the world they have very few
things they don't need that many things
and they're just you know that they
couldn't be happier
but again that doesn't mean the money is
what made that or the lack of money
whatever it's just whatever you do with
yourself ever you see yourself with or
without it yep so we get deep rainicorn
let you close us out no give me money I
need money damn it was this that
Rainicorn closes up